Billy on the street the show where you
go out on the street with your
microphone and just pretty much pester
people was nominated for an Emmy Award
right so you got to go to the Emmys well
yeah that's very excited yeah and you
are here's our house curious about
you're so fascinated by show business
you've always kind of been on the
outside then suddenly you're nominated
you're at the Emmys how did you enjoy it
I'm on the inside Conan and I loved it
yeah yeah I had a great night I met so
many people so many people from my
childhood that I always looked up to I
met Dolly Parton and Tracey Ullman and
you know I was my mind was getting blown
like left and right and then but this is
the most surreal moment I'm in the green
room backstage a small little green room
they have set up and Sean Spicer walks
in yeah he does that bit at the
beginning of the show right and then he
walks into the green room which is where
all the actors hang out I'm standing
there with Jim Parsons who's you know
getting ready to go on and no one would
talk to Sean Spicer he's standing that
is so we it's gonna sit makes me a
little sad for him like he's walking
into this environment and no one's
talking to him the only person who would
talk to him I'm not kidding is a young
Sheldon from the Big Bang from the Big
Bang spin-off Big Bang spinoff yes he
the prequel I'm doing the sequel called
elderly gay Sheldon
so wait a minute so little actor who
plays young Sheldon who's amazing Ian
Armitage I think is his name and so he
he's talking to Sean Spicer and no one
else will talk to Sean Spicer and then
even young Sheldon comes up to me and
Jim Parsons and says is that the real
Sean Spicer like even young Sheldon
thought it might have been Melissa
McCarthy and then when we said yes it's
the real Sean Spicer even young Sheldon
like rolled his eyes and was like oh
[ __ ] I seen it all Conan
you